-My next guest is
a Grammy-winning artist.
This is her brand-new
holiday album,
"A Very Trainor Christmas."
It is out now. It is fantastic.
Here is Meghan Trainor!
Oh, my gosh!
Look at you. Look, the bow.
I mean, stop it.
Oh, I'm so happy!
-I'm so pregnant.
-I am so happy.
And it's wrapped in a bow.
I'm so -- Congratulations.
Lookit. Oh! Look at this!
Yeah!
Oh, my gosh.
How exciting.
-It's real.
-Congratulations.
I'm so excited for you.
How are you feeling?
How has it been being pregnant
during quarantine
and everything?
-It was great,
like, not traveling.
And if I felt sick, I'm like,
"Well, at least I'm home,
you know, and doing interviews
like this."
I was so lucky for that.
And then the only bump
in the road I had was
I got gestational diabetes,
but so many women have it.
And it was just,
like, the unknowing.
Like, I didn't know what it was.
-I don't know what it is.
-And it's like a whole --
It's, like, a genetics thing.
So my mom had it and she didn't
even give me a full warning.
But it's basically I just
watch what I eat now,
I write everything down, I check
my blood, and we're good now.
I've been crushing it.
It's like a game for me.
And I'm winning.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
-So it's nice to know
we're both healthy.
-This is great news.
December is a giant month
for you
because your birthday
is coming up.
-Yes, it is.
-Which is also the same day of
your wedding anniversary,
I believe.
-Yep, I did that.
-Happy birthday.
Happy anniversary.
-Thank you.
-And then Christmas.
How are you going to celebrate
all these things
without overdoing it?
You got to, like, pace yourself.
-I know.
Everyone is worried this year.
I just told them,
like, get me baby stuff.
That's all I need, you know?
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm just like starting to nest.
He's coming around
early February.
So it'll be perfect.
I'll get all my stuff ready.
-Oh, my gosh. I mean, this is --
this is just gonna be
the best Christmas ever.
Let's talk about your new album,
"A Very Trainor Christmas."
This is your first ever
Christmas album.
And I got to tell you,
I love it.
It's a fantastic record,
top to bottom.
It really is a family affair.
The whole family is involved in
this album.
-Yeah, my older brother actually
took that picture
in my living room.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And they wrote all the songs
with me and my brother.
My little brother
produced all the originals,
most of them, with me.
And my dad's playing piano
on "Have Yourself
a Merry Little Christmas."
I got my two cousins
to come over.
And I told them, "I'm pregnant.
Also sing backgrounds
on 'Rudolph.'"
You know?
It was a big family project.
-How awesome is that?
It is 18 songs.
It is jam-packed.
I mean, you get your money's
worth with this one.
It's classics.
-Yeah.
-But there's also
some covers on here of, like,
you know --
I mean, there's brand-new ones.
But there's also covers.
"It's Beginning to Look
a Lot Like Christmas."
"Winter Wonderland."
"White Christmas" with
Seth MacFarlane, by the way,
is the --
right now, it is number one
on Billboard's
Adult Contemporary chart.
-Whoo! I know!
-Congratulations on that.
-Number one!
-That guy is unbelievable too.
He's so talented.
-He's so good.
-And funny.
But my favorite jam --
can you guess or no?
-Ugh. I don't know. Maybe, um...
Is it a cover or an original?
-It's a cover.
-Okay. Is it "Last Christmas"?
-It's "Last Christmas."
-Oh!
-No one can cover --
-I got it!
-No one can cover that song
and I go like, "Well, nice try."
This is fantastic, and I love
not only your singing on it,
but the production
and the way it starts
with like
a "whu-whu-whu-whu-whu-whu-whu"
and then grows up and -- I go --
I love it.
I go, "Dude, she hit a home run
with this one."
-I didn't realize how much
pressure that would be.
A lot of people were like,
"I really hate when people cover
this song,
but you did a great job."
I was like, "Oh, my God."
-It's a tough one to cover.
I think that one's a tou--
-It's tough.
-The other tough one is
The Waitresses'
"Christmas Wrapping."
You can't really do it.
-Yeah.
-Like The Waitresses did.
But this one was -- it's --
The whole record is great.
But I love the production
on that.
Your voice is great.
It's just perfect.
The keyboard. The sound is
just great on that one.
I love that.
-Thank you so much.
-The whole -- I just love
Christmas albums too.
-Yeah, I love what you do
with Dolly.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
-Queen Dolly Parton.
It's great!
-We'll talk about that
some other time.
I was sweating bombs.
I go, "I can't sing this song."
What's wrong with people?
But it was so much fun.
It's Dolly. It was the best.
-Yeah.
-But then you get -- you go,
"Great, here's a new song
called 'Holidays,'
and here's Earth, Wind & Fire."
And I go --
It's just brilliant.
How'd the collaboration
come about?
-I heard that -- they've
always been so nice to me,
but I heard they
would be willing to do
a duet with me on this album.
And I was like,
"It has to be an original.
And I have to show my heroes
like, 'You raised me.
You taught me what music is.
I'm going to make you proud.'"
And I got with
my two favorite musicians,
Mike Sabath, Eddie Benjamin.
They're children.
They're like 20 years old.
And we all, like,
got together -- tested --
we're all safe -- got together,
and we wrote this song
in an evening,
and we're like, "We just want it
to be a party."
We studied their music.
We played it all day.
-It's very Earth, Wind & Fire
but perfectly you.
Perfectly you too
'cause I was like --
[ Vocalizes ]
Dude, I was --
I mean, you know.
-We were like, "We have to have
a horn section, a breakdown."
Like, it was math.
-Yeah. But I love the song.
And you're performing it
for us tonight,
which I'm very excited
and thankful for.
We're very in the theme
this year.
So I'm so thankful for that.
But first, you're always up for
doing something fun on our show,
which we love about you.
When we come back,
you and I are going to play
a musical game called
"Google Translate Songs."
More with Meghan Trainor
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody!
-Whoo!